brother jack how are we doing man uh i'm
52
and a month ago i married a 49 year old
virgin
okay so is this your first marriage it
is my second marriage
second marriage okay and i'm assuming
this is her first marriage exactly
okay all right so you're a month in and
you are 52
so you're halfway home right and um
i don't know why i always go to talking
about death sorry about that but
hey you're living your best life at 52
you got remarried
and you married a 49 year old who's
never had sex before
right okay right i'm assuming that's why
you're calling
yeah yeah um we're having you just call
me with a retirement question man just
how do we move the 401 over whatever i
won't know how to answer that but
i can at least do as good as hogan can
right but all right so go ahead
yeah i mean this is a unique situation
i i i feel like we're
having some intimacy challenges where
we've had some attempts to consummate
and with varying degrees of success but
there's a lot of fear of physical
intimacy
with her and i just need some tools and
knowledge
to kind of help because she um
basically you know was single for so
long that she just kind of
divorced herself from that physical side
of pleasure was a
foreign word i think um
so so she's kind of reintegrating you
know even that language into that part
of her life
and uh i i we knew this going in
it's not a surprise um we
we just are gonna take our time with it
but i'm just
you know i'm like who are you jack
you're like the greatest guy i've ever
met
because you know what i was expecting
hey you know what i was expecting i was
expecting that you to say
what's wrong with my wife and you're not
you are
asking me hey man how can i grow
how can i learn some stuff how can i
create a safe environment
brother i'm telling you right now if
there's more jacks in the world we don't
have all this nonsense
right so you've made my heart feel good
and i i
i'm just grateful to even be able to
talk to you today um just even your
patience and your kindness is awesome
so a couple of um broad basic questions
here does your
does your wife have a history of trauma
or is did she just never find the right
person
and virginity was a was a thing she
wanted to hang on to
and then suddenly it turned into the
late 20s and late 30s and then suddenly
she's
almost 50 and then she finds the right
guy or did she have
a history there that she really needed
to part ways with intimacy
and any sort of vulnerability there
that's a great question she had
the only trauma that really uh played on
her ability to
uh form relationships with people was
you know she
poured herself into her work after a
death in the family
okay and that was hugely traumatic for
her
and you're right time slipped away um
the opportunities
i guess i i hate to use the word dried
up that's such a horrible
term but um
life happened right and we we live in
this world where
uh if you don't if you don't you know
go to your four-year undergraduate
degree and then find somebody and you'll
date for
18 and a half months and then get
engaged and then get married or you get
your master's degree and then you're 29
and
if you don't follow the road right
there's something wrong with you right
and so
i don't and yeah and her purity
became part of her identity because i
mean it was
obviously her you know we wanted to do
things according to god's plan
and she did her whole life so that
combined with everything else just kind
of
ended up with her where she's at so sure
so
um i guess my my meta question is
is she in interested in this does she
want to
have a great sex life with you in a
intimate marriage
and a fun rambunctious um no holds
barred relationship with you
i can't speak to rambunctious but i
can't tell you that
um she wants a normal uh life in that
area
okay i'm gonna tell you don't settle for
normal
okay normal is boring settle for
rambunctious
settle for two people that um
cultivate desire in one another and
yeah so we live in this funky place and
there's several great books you can read
on on just the evolution of marriage in
fact me and my friend rachel are going
to have a whole event on this coming up
in the next few months
but we've traded in the last 30 to 40
years we've traded
safety for intimacy so you meet somebody
and you're attracted to them and your
heart races and you can't just wait to
make out right
and you practice safety is he going to
show up when he says he is
is she going to return my phone call
that first time one of you gets sick and
the other one brings food by
you cultivate safety and then what
happens is you begin to trade
safety doesn't is is butts heads with
desire
right to be crass about it nobody wants
to make out with their mom
or their brother right or their or their
sister
that's safe i know that person there is
no desire there
none right but there's safety
and then as you be as you feel safe with
somebody and y'all two
are you know 50. you're halfway through
life
you all understand safety you all
understand independence you all
understand those things
what they didn't tell us in premarital
counseling what they didn't tell us
in grad school didn't tell us this at
all and our parents
certainly didn't model this because they
didn't know is that once you achieve
safety once you have the hard money
conversations and the 401 questions and
you make a will together
once you feel safety then and it usually
happens in your 30s and begins in your
40s and 50s especially
you have to practice desire you've got
to
cultivate desire as though you are
practicing safety early on in your
relationship
and it feels weird to practice desire
because that's not what romeo and juliet
told us they said we're just gonna walk
into a room and be like oh my gosh there
you are
or you know jack and rose they didn't
you know jack didn't see rose on the
titanic and be like
what we need to do is to practice
intimacy nah man they were like making
out in some weird car and then they died
to get well he died
because she didn't let him on the door
like a sucker he could have fit on the
door
but here's the thing so they are
they're you gotta practice it and it
feels weird to put sex on a calendar
it feels weird in your case to
be intentional about going slow and
saying hey
we're going to have a relational goal of
here and the moment she feels unsafe she
gets to call it and then we're out and
we're going to go again
and you're going to have to practice
patience and you're going to have to
practice
um what i like it comes from emily
nagaski i'm going to recommend a book
for you two guys to read together
but you're going to have to practice
turning on all the ons and turning off
all the offs
intimacy especially in a marriage
relationship is
so often ecosystem related it's
environmental
right here's a good example my wife
likes to have all of the dishes done and
the kitchen clean
before anything else happens in in the
evening
and i became so insecure i started
taking that personally
and i the story i told myself was
she would rather have a clean kitchen
than hook up with this
nice piece of meat right and i don't
know if you can see me right now jack
i'm smoking hot okay so i just i got to
where i was thinking i'm not really but
i i that's why i do radio
i got to thinking man i can't believe
that she would trade a clean kitchen
over this
and it wasn't until we sat down and had
some hard conversations that i realized
she can't stop judging herself she can't
stop feeling a
entire culture that says if you don't
have a kitchen it looks like this if you
don't have a heart that looks like this
if you don't have a period of any of
these sentences
you're not a true wife you're not a true
mom you're not a true
fill in the blank right i didn't know
all that baggage that comes along how
much it sucks
to try to navigate the world as a
working professional wife
mother all that stuff it's hard and so
dude what i decided to do is stop taking
it personal
and then i try to clean the kitchen man
if that's
if that's what it is dude i've got you
on that right
and it took us having this conversation
about what's the environment look like
what are the offs and what are the ons
the book i want you two to read this is
not a faith-based book um you mentioned
that y'all are both christians and you
have a
a christian ethic this is not a
christian book it's the best book i've
ever read when it comes to
talking about um establishing establish
establishing good grief james we need a
dictionary on the show
establishing um sexual intimacy
right and so a blow by the parts that
you don't like but there is
an extraordinary discussion um and it's
written for women
but it's called come as you are by emily
nagoski
and um it is exceptional
when it comes to you recommend that book
before i'd recommend y'all both read it
together
and it will probably make her blush it
will probably give her freedom here's
one of the ultimate
um thesis of that book life is too short
to not have an incredible sex life
it's just too short life is too short
to pretend that guys just have a sex
drive and girls just have
a sex drive light those are not true
either of those are not true they're not
real
and so she cuts through a lot of the
myths and then she gives you a lot of
tools for how couples can
grow together and learn together and um
how women especially can
learn these offs and ons and the in the
brakes and the gas pedals which is a
different
meta metaphor than drive it's a great
book for you all to read together but
it's going to give you common language
and that's what you all need here it
sounds like brother
you have a a heart of safety
a heart of go slow and so what i want to
do is give her some tools and give her
some permission
to don't use the word normal in your
house anymore you got it
yes we're not gonna be normal there's
nothing abnormal about y'all too by the
way
right there's not you're not a normal
guy the heart and compassion you have
for your wife isn't normal
um her being a 49 year old virgin is not
normal i guess i say not normal it's not
common right that's a better word to use
it's not common
in y'all's decision to love each other
recklessly with abandon and i want every
single 50 year old couple listening to
this show
i want every single 40 year old couple
30 year old couple mid-20s
couple i want you to get into the
mindset of
establishing desire romeo and juliet
lied to you that's not real that was two
tim
teenagers throwing a temper tantrum that
ended up in a murder-suicide thing it
was it's stupid it's not
real what's real is is cultivating
desire
cultivating mystery cultivating a spirit
of
i refuse to have anything less than
a just a rambunctious extraordinary sex
life with my
husband and my wife i just don't and so
what do we have to do to get there
and first that looks different for every
single couple anyone who tells you like
well you should be
idiots you work it out together you all
build this together
so jack i love your heart i was going to
tell him to call me back
you don't need to call me back jack i'm
i'm i'm curious on all of 50 different
levels
don't call me back on this one i love
you and i'm so glad
i got to talk to you today brother